foreign
university has honored a scientist who
is just nine years old Bobby Wilson is
fascinated by bugs but last year her
mission to catch spotted Lantern flies
made national headlines Bradley
Blackburn has the details on how a
frightening encounter led to a
celebration
it has red and brown wings with black
spots and nine-year-old Bobby Wilson can
tell you exactly what it is
last fall she learned about this
invasive species in school and wanted to
help she found a bug spray recipe on
Tick Tock good job I mix water dish soap
and apple cider vinegar she was using it
outside her New Jersey home when a
neighbor called the police a little
black woman walking and spraying stuff
on the sidewalks and trees I don't know
what the hell she's doing scares me
though Bobby's mom says it was racial
profiling those exact words in another
town another state
I could be grieving Yale University
assistant professor at Joma opara heard
Bobby's story and decided to take this
young entomologist under her Wing oh
yeah Bobby belongs here
Bobby is yell she invited Bobby to
campus to meet scientists who look like
her
[Applause]
Friday Bobby was back to see the first
spotted lanternfly specimens added to
the Yale Peabody Museum of Natural
History collection those insects were
gathered by Bobby herself how does it
make you feel to know that these bugs
are going to be in this Museum
happy and proud a young girl who's
flying high and now has the bug for a
career in science for CBS Saturday
morning Bradley Blackburn New Haven
Connecticut
wow turning something awful around what
a way to do it that's right